okay please
cover up the fact that i still don't
know how to spell avocado
it's a-v-o-c-a-d-o
you guys here's the real question
here's the real question you guys
kidding me i have to shoot my fifth
animal special should i roll the dice or
should i take my presents you're not
gonna wear that are you
no no yeah
should i take my pros out no you need
the edge fucked up should i go for it
what does it do i see nobody
[Music]
i'm very excited to retire
[Laughter]
looking straight up is reverse cowgirl
which i'm normally doing for whatever
reason these days from this thing from
this side
and then um like that's fall back and
like yeah perfect
that's perfect but
it's right there okay so
yeah okay all right actually this mark
but we'll set a personal here
if i could be right in between there
that might be yes i think i'm gonna
probably my um
sound i'm gonna have to be like maybe
ten percent louder than this and if i
move it around just ignore me like
during the show you won't need to adjust
anything so i will let you mix yourself
with the distance yeah
i'll bring things closer sometimes and
go you know what i mean but
[Music]
should we just walk through the whole
show
hi everybody i'm hoodie cummings welcome
to the show
um can this go up ten percent
yeah i just everything feels like it's
not loud enough i want to be like very
loud
[Music]
very uh
hello hello check check that's
[Applause]
excuse me let me take my porridge
my
creamed spinach
so bro look at this ah they did take
away abortion access
i can't even get this hanger down
we are going to do what women do best
so
okay so is this going to work
all right oh
come
on ah look at that oop
see this is why i'm not a i'm just not
wife material
okay
the bow should be in the back so
scalp is just gross to see
spray
[Applause]
spraying on her hair
there we go do i look less bald
i already have a blister
alright blister
i already have a
blister greatness
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and remember to take a couple seconds on
stage give her all your love ben thank
you guys so much for joining the show
[Applause]
you now are you love her give it up for
my friend whitney
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yeah
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three
minutes
daddy daddy daddy daddy and i deserve to
see this v-neck and this dick that is
the move that's illegal in the nfl i
would like a big beaver magazine please
i made 74 levels for this bullshit shit
we put it on our face
we can plie down to the spelling bee i'm
on the moon
it's like two crocodile eyes coming out
of the pond it's dark
[Music]
i feel like that was good
can i have my ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married